*muffled* oh my goodness you are so big oh!
I gotcha! I'm not gonna let go! I'm never gonna let go!
never!
Oh, I let go..
Here comes a Bubble
Bubble!
You are so small!
Hi guys, I wanna wish you all a very Merry Christmas
and a Happy Holidays to everyone that doesn't celebrate Christmas
I hope you guys are currently with your friends and family and
I am very happy to say that I am home
which is something that I haven't been able to say for a long time
oh! ho! ho! here come maggie
that waddle
oh maggie hu-hoo! oh ma-goo-goo!
oh my goo-bee
oh my goo-bee!
oh my goodness ma goo-ber!
aww maggie it's okay!
aww! Thank you!
Yeah I am home and uh it's good to be here
It's good to be around my family again
It's good to see my friends again and
It always just feels calmer here than LA
mostly because it is, traffic is less, there's less people and generally
it's just a bit more easy going
and it always feels grounding to be around my friends
and I was really happy to be able to do the charity live stream
I still don't know the final tally of the amount raised but
I know we were very close to our 150 thousand dollar goal.
But moreover than that I just like being here because it reminds me of
you know
why I started all of this and why I decided to do this because
I-I-I think...
I think early on in my career on youtube, huh, my "career" on youtube
I landed on the right attitude
towards what I wanted to do with this channel
it was to spread joy
and bring happiness and do some good for the world around me and
and I look back four and a half years ago
when I first started in this very house
and I just see the progress that we've made since that time
and I look back and I remember all the different things we've done
all the different challenges that we have faced and I say we as in you and me
I'm not talking about me and my friends
we've faced challenged ourselves but like
you and I
we have come a long, long way
and some of you may have not been here this whole time and that's totally fine
I know there's so many of you out there and it's hard to imagine
the sheer magnitude of
living everyday of your life with more and more people walking through the door.
But I remember back here, back when I first started and I could communicate with every single subscriber individually
and the wonder of that time, it was a beautiful thing.
And not saying it's turned into an ugly thing, if anything it's even more beautiful than it was before because
the charity live stream that we did yesterday is an indication of that very same spirit that we started the channel with
(bubble screeches)
Hey
none of that
Bubble
I know you want up
but it's Maggie's turn
okay?
(Bubble whines)
aaah
don't whine
nu-nu-nu-nu-no
(Bubble sneezes)
a-snuff, bless you
anyway that same spirit that I started the channel with and the idea that we were going to spread joy and we were gonna do good and we
(Bubble barks)
I'm trying to talk here!
I'm trying to talk none of that, wrong!
I'll boop you on the nose!
oh-jeez welp here's lucy
Hi lucy!
welcome to party
I was in the middle of something and then you all interrupt
now sit and stay still!
Sit still!
Good girl Lucy, I know you can't sit in my lap cause you're too huge,
but I will play with you after the video's done okay?
It's fascinating to see that same spirit burning
and it's not just my heart and the hearts of my friends whom have been inspired to do things
and it's even weird to think that I inspired my friends to do good but Bob told me as much
during the live stream yesterday and it really... those words really resonated with me.
Like knowing that I introduced this concept of... not that I started this concept, not by anyone
but I introduced this concept that what I do here on youtube and playing games and having fun with
with friends and family and you guys
could lead to good in the world.
That's an amazing feeling and I always get in a mood of self-reflection when I come back here
and I know it's easy to get lost in the...
the dismay of like this year, 2016 has been quite a year
and I know it's easy to get lost in the general pessimism
of what seems to go on, because in this day n' age everything is about sharing
but I think sometimes people forget that it's so important to share the right things
and it's so important to share the right message
because as a species we're programmed to look at disaster and be like "oh! that is fascinating!"
but we gotta remember that we look at that as a warning so that we don't
allow that to control our lives and when that's all we hear
even on the internet or in our daily lives and that becomes
like the chorus of our entire existence. Like the theme song of our life becomes this depressing parade
and that's not what I ever want to do
I only ever want to bring joy and I always feel
more connected with that when I am with my family and with my friends
I am doing things that I am so proud of doing and I'm making videos that make me laugh as much as they make you laugh
and
I just wanted to say that I am very, very happy
with where I am and with who I am
and even though I'm 27 years old
I'm not done growing up
I've come a long, long way
from the person I was when started this channel
and
I've hit road blocks and I've hit obstacles and I've hit challenges and I have overcome them and some I have not overcome...
yet
but I am so happy with
the fact that I have been able to stay true to this course that we
you and I
are able to stay true to what we do here on this channel
which is at it's core
to spread joy and happiness to everyone that needs it and that is why I am happy to be home
and while I'm here, I plan to do some videos with my mother
who you guys have only seen briefly in pictures and in small snippets of videos but
I have an idea, she has been learning to do VERY, VERY good nail decoration
so I think I'm gonna have her do my nails because she needs to practice and I need to get my nails done because they're horrid
and I think I'm going to have her try to play a game
and I think I know exactly the game she needs to play, I believe I am going to try to get my mom to play Five Nights at Freddy's
and she is not gonna know what the hell to do but my mom
is the most unintentionally hilarious person I know, I could start a book series on texts from my mom, texts from my mom
she is THE funniest texter on the face of the earth and if you guys wanna see some of those let me know down in the comments
if you wanna see a specific game for us to play let us know down in the comments and expect the nail painting video very soon
but for now I'm gonna celebrate Christmas with my doggies and celebrate Christmas with my family
and I'm gonna spend a good while kinda relaxing while at the same time getting videos to you guys because
the thing I plan to do while I am here is play nothing but indie horror games because
I have been stock piling lists of them and saving it just for this occasion when I am back home
in my old recording room and in my old recording set up and
able to make videos for you guys so that should be a lot of fun
but at the end of it all just thank you guys so much for being here with me on this amazing journey
that is not yet over
and I have no idea when it's gonna end but hopefully the spirit of what we do here always carries on
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
thank you Bubble for being a rambunctious little stinker!
Thank you Maggie for being such a good girl!
and thank you everybody again for watching.
And as always I will see you
In the next video
Buh-byeee!
yes, bye-bye Bubble!
bye-bye!
Ew that's gross